I just don't want to fight anymore
you know I have like this much fight in
me left I don't want to do it Dance Moms
star Abby Lee Miller fights back tears
and anger after quitting the lifetime
reality show you said that you were
manipulated disrespected and used day in
and day out by men what did that mean
not the crew the sound guys Steve my the
camera guys Adam and everybody they're
wonderful to me very very kind and
respectful the producers I think the
word respect I think the word trust and
I think the word thank you it was
missing from my relationship with the
production company Cheryl Burke will now
be the host I'm glad that someone who
has worked on a network show for as long
as she has on Dancing with the Stars is
going to see what I've been working with
for seven seasons
Abby is potentially facing up to ten
years in prison after pleading guilty to
bankruptcy fraud last June are you
prepared to spend time in prison no we
see you as a tough lady
that's a different type of tough yeah
did you decide to quit because of what
could come no absolutely not
let's make that clear absolutely not I
chose to quit because I don't want to
fight for a great idea I don't want to
fight for better music I don't want to
fight for a bigger costume budget wait
till Cheryl Burke deals with that it
Dancing with the Stars they have two
floors an entire building seamstresses
this is sewing rhinestoning fringe she's
gonna have to run downtown to Santee
alley can buy something off the street
in her car at 4:30 in rush hour traffic
after we wrap when everything's closing
cuz that's what I did for six years and
I
bet you she's treated differently I bet
you the budget is completely different
and I bet you she is never driving her
car with her desk getting parking
tickets that she has to pay walking up
and down the streets looking for fabric
on her feet
so you think lifetimes gonna treat her
differently hell yes so could this be
much ado about nothing and this be a
situation where you're just angry and
then when the dust settles Abby Lee
Miller comes back or season just is not
gonna settle until that producer is dead
and they cremate him and that dust is
there that's the dust just to button it
up you're done I'm finished working
under these conditions yes a source
close to the Dance Moms production tells
et that Abby was unreasonable during
filming and that they are now breathing
a sigh of relief that Cheryl Burke will
lead the remainder of the season
you